hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm a property investor
and on this video on youtube i'm going
to be in depth
answering your questions around property
investment
so those you might see my videos pop up
on instagram or tiktok
this is the place to get a more in-depth
discussion
and and deep dive into some questions
that are holding you back in property so
listen up
drop your comments drop your questions
below in the video
and then what i'll do is i'll try my
very best to answer them on next week's
video so let's see what questions we had
from last week's youtube video
by the way if you enjoy my channel
please let me know i spend so much time
doing these videos
for you to help you in property so let
me know by smashing the like button also
don't forget to subscribe and turn the
notification bell on imagine if you
asked me a question
and i answer it really eloquently but
you never know i answered it because you
weren't subscribed that would be
terrible so subscribe
turn the bell on and let's see what we
got so we've got uh jason stevenson said
hi samuel have you ever bought over the
guide
price i have um
i have bought properties over the guide
price and
firstly the guide price the asking price
it doesn't matter what matters is what
the property's worth
to you so i've had situations where i'm
buying a property even not from auction
from estate agents
whereby i'm thinking there's a big plot
of land
on the side of the house and i'm
thinking that house is on on the market
for 150
000 pounds but i know i could
extend it or i could build on the side
of it um
so so i might pay 160 000 pounds but
then get planning permission which might
cost me a few thousand pounds and then
boom i've pushed the value right up so
paying over the guide price isn't always
a bad thing
it usually is but it's about what's the
property worth to you
as an investment also with the guide
price
if you're buying from auction you've got
three prices you've got
the guide price which is how much the
property is advertised
at but then at auction it will usually
always sell above the guide price
you've then got the reserve price which
is the
lowest that the seller will actually
accept
that's usually got to be within 10 of
the guide price and then you have the
purchase price
so those are the prices that you have so
it's not unusual to go over the guide
price
especially if the guide price has been
set really low
just to attract investors into the room
i hope that helps
next question razvan gabriel
what percentage of your money do you
usually pull out from a brr deal and how
long does it take
great question so i'm always aiming
to pull out 100 of my money so if i put
in
a hundred thousand pounds into a deal
let's say fifty thousand pounds purchase
price
fifty thousand pounds refurb renovation
and everything else
hundred grand all in i would aim to then
get the value at a at a higher amount to
the point where i can pull out the
entire
investment that i put in to begin with
however does that always happen
no it doesn't if it did then
the person who could guarantee that that
would always happen would have
an unlimited amount of properties
because they just go
just keep recycling over and over
forever whereas in reality what happens
is sometimes you pull it all out
other times you might pull out 90
percent if you're really unlucky you
might pull out 85
um but pulling out less than 85
is really bad news because you may as
well just buy it
and not add value at all but yeah
generally speaking though i do pull out
i'd say 95 of my money all right darren
would you recommend starting property
investment with buy to let
mortgage and would this affect buying my
own home
in the future um
yeah so it wouldn't particularly affect
it every
every mortgage lender is different what
why lender wants to see is that you're
gonna be able to pay
back the mortgage and you're gonna be
able to pay the interest so
if you buy a buy to let property as long
as that buy to let property is is
ticking over nicely it's all working
okay
what the lender wants to see is that
you're going to be able to pay back
that mortgage and you're going to pay
the interest payments so
if you've got a buy to let property that
you own and the tenants are in there and
they're paying their mortgage and it's
all going fine
it shouldn't affect you getting a
residential mortgage to live in
um so would you recommend starting with
buy to let mortgage is it going to
affect you down the line
no in fact if you do get a
residential mortgage first that will
actually help you
because if you've got a residential
mortgage you're a property owner
so it's going to help you get by to that
mortgages my advice would probably be to
speak to a broker
about your situation because there's a
whole host of factors they're going to
want to look at
your earnings your credit so probably
speak to a broker and work out what's
best but that's just the general
idea of how they work okay um kyoubrai
says hi samuel i'm 16 respect
i've been watching your videos for about
a year now and i have been to a crash
course and read your books and love them
well done i'm not sure what i can do at
16 but i've started my own business that
brings in four to five hundred pounds
each month dude well done
listen man the fact that you are 16
you came to a free property investors
crash course
and now you're making four or 500 pounds
a month um
you're going to be super successful
buddy and i'm really impressed
so your question is what do you think i
should do to get started in property
recommended i do thanks for everything
um well you've been to a crash course so
you probably know the basics of
how to find a deal how to work out the
return on investment
about the concept of packaging deals and
selling them
you probably met some really cool people
uh you've got a business now that's
making you four to five hundred pounds a
month
um what would i do if i were you i'd
probably use that four or five hundred
pound a month
um to to join networking associations
to start putting yourself around
investors um
i would get myself a car i'd be driving
up and down the country viewing
properties
um and immerse yourself into the
property industry but you're 16 bro and
you're making 4 500
a month already in business keep doing
what you're doing
surround yourself by winners surround
yourself by people
who are successful i think that's the
biggest thing i would say so that it
feels normal
uh you need any help drop us a shout
message me on instagram
all right jacob hi samuel i'm 16 years
old oh my goodness all these 16 year
olds what's going on this is crazy
i'm 16 years old and i want to start in
property but family doesn't believe in
me and think i'm stupid
um i need training to be successful like
you they don't believe i can do it and i
was wondering if you had any thoughts on
this as i look up to you very much keep
up the good work thank you so much
uh jacob firstly is i can i can relate
to what you're saying i was people
thought i was stupid practically my
whole life when i was a kid
i used to have to sit on i literally sat
on a special needs desk when i was at
school
um i wasn't very good academically
um some people within my family thought
i was stupid so i feel your pain and i
get you my advice to you
would be to just prove them wrong with
actions not with words don't tell them
don't try and convince them don't be
like
look look at this video that samuel did
look it does work
and try and convince them just go and do
it
and show them and when you start showing
people success then people are like oh
wow
i remember um someone in my family um
said samuel is thick but he doesn't know
how to make money
i was about 17 at the time and i
remember like what what
what what a strange backhanded
compliment he's thick
like he's stupid but he doesn't know how
to make money
but even though it was a diss it was
like at least okay
he's good at making money though and
then as time went on it's like actually
he's not that stupid he's pretty smart
so you're gonna show people okay i
believe in you though bro
i really do believe in you and um yeah
again like i said before get around
people
if your family are saying you're stupid
and they don't believe in you
you're 16 probably living at home i'm
not saying like move out or anything
you're young
but but at least find some people that
do believe in you
and start spending time with friends
mentors
people online social media groups that
do believe in you because that
environment is really important big boss
when doing interest-only mortgage how do
i reduce the risk of paying
more when interest rises fix the rates
fix the rates and make sure you've got
plenty of cushion
in the in within the rent and the
mortgage so if you've got a mortgage
that's 500 pounds and the rent is 600
pounds
that leaves you in a really dangerous
position because if the interest rate
goes up a little bit
then suddenly you're not going to make
it it scuppers the deal
whereas if you're making a rent of a
thousand pounds and the mortgage is 200
pounds
mortgage interest rates are gonna have
to go up a lot
to even to to even mean that you're a
break-even point
so that's the first thing second thing
is to fix the interest rates
you can fix interest rates for five
sometimes even 10 years
i mean what's going to happen in 10
years well firstly your interest rate
won't go up
but what will go up probably is the rent
house prices rent everything goes up so
that's probably what i would say to
protect yourself hope that helps
alexander jones i wanted to ask you
whether you think buying houses on a
single let and building solely a single
let portfolio is still a good way to go
while starting out
i'm 26 years old i have five single buy
to let's and i'm trying to save up more
and i'm planning on remortgaging two
next year to buy more
each property makes me between 150 and
250 pounds per month
would you suggest this is good or should
i get more creative i feel like i'm
i'm a small-time landlord and i've not
really breached into lease option
agreement service accommodation at all
just interested in your thoughts i
appreciate it man so first thing i want
to say alexander again congrats you know
you're 26 you're a young guy you got
five houses that's great
a lot of people at 26 haven't even got
one house yet um
you know so so that's really good
celebrate what you've done
moving forward dude i would definitely
start doing stuff more creative because
if you're only making 150 to 250 pound a
month per property
you got five so you're making what like
800 pound a month
do you really want to have 50 houses
and it's going to take you a long time
to do it you it's just a
slow old school way to to to get to make
money
and also there's section 24 you've got
the tenant eviction bans
you've got all the tenants rights you've
only got to have one problem property
and it can take out the profits of two
or three other houses
so i'm not about growing this way
okay i don't think you should grow wide
i think you should grow this way
and what i mean by that is rather than
saying oh well what i'll do is i'll buy
lots and lots and lots and lots and lots
and lots of little houses like this
and then one day i'll grow bigger just
just grow up like that so
i would just be saying every time i do a
deal it's going to be a bigger deal than
my last deal
i don't want to make 150 pounds a month
per property i want to make a thousand
pounds a month per property
so yeah hmos serviced accommodation
brr recycling your cash 100
you need to get more creative what
you're doing is slow
painful and it will take you 50 years
before you can comfortably retire
all right richard harrington time got
property 4 5 and 6 at the moment
after watching you boom great job i'm
glad
i'm glad to see people you know i've got
kids on the channel 16 years old and
then i've got people with like five six
houses
um i'm really glad to see that all
properties are in my local area of south
wales within five miles of each other
my question is how do you manage
properties all over the country do you
have a state agency for you if so what
do you pay 10 20
i can see properties in ne at the moment
that i think there is value in okay
so richard great question again congrats
um
uh i grew my portfolio like
how i exactly recommended not to a
minute ago i got loads of little houses
and i also
scattered them all across the country
had our houses literally
wherever i went i'd have i'd be like oh
i've got a house there or if i met
someone new and then oh i live in this
area i live in liverpool i live in
doncaster
i live in birmingham i live in bradford
i live in middlesbrough i've got a house
there
like that was kind of how i grew my
portfolio um
agents typically would charge about 10
to manage a single occupancy house like
a family home
um the problem is what i found was is
that when you've got
it takes a while to get a good agent
where you're like
that agent is good so when you buy a
house in a brand new area you'll get an
agent and they won't be very good
and then you buy and you have to
systemize it set it up
and then finally you'll get a good agent
and you're like brilliant
but that process doing that process in
10 different towns
20 different towns is really hard and
then what happens is when you've just
about got a good area
and you've got a good set set up then
somewhere else
that letting agent will go bust or that
letting agent
the the the manager will go sick and
they'll go i've got a replacement
manager though and they'll be rubbish
and and i found that having lots of
different houses and lots of different
areas
um when you're talking about buy to let
it's hard to scale um i ended up having
to employ somebody to manage the
managers which was fine
but it is it's hard work so i would
advise
unless you're doing deals whereby you're
not tenants aren't involved or
you know if you're buying like an
apartment block or you're building an
apartment block and you've got a bunch
of tenants all in one
space that's kind of different or if
they're commercial tenants again that's
kind of different
but if you're buying buy to lex or even
hmos
i would say probably stick to one or two
areas so you've got north
wales or wherever you said stick there
maybe one other area but
i would keep it to two areas and then
dominate and also every time you do
another deal i'd make sure it's a bigger
deal than the last deal you did
and go bigger and bigger and bigger
growing this way instead of this way
i hope that helps so whether you're 16
60 dreaming about doing your first deal
or in your 10th deal i appreciate you
being a subscriber
of the youtube channel i'm really
honored and humbled to be able to help
people and see people grow in their
journey
um if you've got a question about
property comment below
and subscribe and i'll see you guys next
time
[Music]
you